location
[Music]
Sons following in their mama's Footsteps
in an emotional new song I do think that
my kids are they do have some kind of
musical talent and that Town's featured
in the singer's music video for her new
track acrostico a love letter to her
boys Milan and Sasha whom she shares
with X Gerard PK sing and play the piano
as their mom proudly watches on
it is
I don't know if they're gonna be
professionals in this business special
musicians I don't care I just I just
want him to have music in their lives
because I think it's it's gonna be a
companionship down the road the little
ones Parts translate to my love serves
as an anesthetic to pain makes me feel
better I'm here for whatever you need
you came to complete what I am they
really take everything from you you know
the video seems to also be a message
about the recent changes in their lives
following Shakira split from their dad
back in June if it weren't because of
that moment I wouldn't have two kids and
we're probably not formed the family
that I have formed today the visual
shows Sasha and Milan's room packed up
in April Shakira announced she and her
kids are moving away from Barcelona
where they were raised
[Music]
[Applause]
that translates to even if life treated
me like this I will be strong just for
you all I want is your happiness and to
be with you mothers are always
thinking and in double guessing and and
wondering for doing things right or not
you know this isn't the first time Milan
and Sasha have been involved with their
mom's music
foreign
music video with Rao Alejandro my little
one came up with the idea of the robot
and my eldest one came up with the idea
of the green fire it's incredible what
kids can do right their imagination is
Limitless and and they're so pure and so
uncorrupted and they're always ready to
create if we allow them as far as Sasha
and Milan's musical Journey continuing
goes Shakira's letting them decide Sasha
he seems to be very musical but you know
you never know what what they will want
for their own lives what's important is
that they that whatever they do they do
it with passion and that they find a
real vocation and follow it
[Music]